uh oh yo this Taylor dude that uh is
assaulting these models you saw this no
I we were talking about this this guy
that has these Chinese boys oh I love
this guy have we talked about this no we
haven't bro this is unbelievable no this
is like this your timeline is different
this is on Tik Tok like Instagram reals
it's this random thing the guy lives in
like Asia or something like that he's
basically a tailor but his marketing for
what he does is he like sexually
assaults and harasses the guys that are
putting on his suits I don't even know
if he's gay in real life Tom seura
actually just went out there and I think
connected with the guy and it was it was
actually really impressive I was like oh
[__] Tom is like really into the Nuance
Niche parts of the internet like he
enjoys that [__] cuz you got to be deep
to see this and uh I don't even know if
the guy's gay or not but watch what he
does no he gay Chinese boy how old are
you 21 say it again I'm 21 are you sure
you're Chinese yes I'm chines [__] can't
believe this guy he's a [__] Filipino
wannabe Chinese [__] oh Jesus
are you sure you're 21 I'm 21 are you 20
[__] one I'm going to bite you this
is the how old are you I'm 21 are you
Filipino no you're Chinese yes two
buttons two
glorious mother of Cl buttons my dot dot
dot dot hand needle and thread pick
stitching on a narrow semi notal pel
check out the peak of the pocket square
undersized flat Pockets that are slanted
pick stitch and fully lined a fully
functional cup still think he's Filipino
Chinese just look and feel different he
is definitely a Filipino but he is gift
wrapped absolutely gift wrapped in my
four def let me open up the young boy
Chinese or Filipino I like opening up
young boys and show you how he is just
gift wrapped in Manila Shanghai
seu Beijing everywhere else in the
Philippines all across China young half
Chinese boy are you happy yes
okay at the end he went okay and it kind
of sounded straight I think he's
straight stick yeah crazy this is
uncomfortable they know it's going to
happen they go there for this yeah what
are these why that's what I don't that's
Weir I need to unpack all of it bro why
are these dudes these young men signing
up for this they want a good suit bro
they're Chinese they don't know anybody
who can make clothing so the
actual son this guy been making that
suit since he was four years
old yeah I mean this is insane no that's
what you do in China is you get a custom
made to measure Beast bug suit and like
yeah we did that in Singapore and they
didn't fondle our [__] all they were
doing they didn't go to the right guy
went to the right guy suit you still
wear that suit gift R GI if you were
gift I was GI R if I was gift W imagine
what would you do to be gift W you
wouldn't let him grab your [__] cake
a little bit and slap the [__] out of it
hard that was crazy he was following
through that was disturbing it's like
that's why he's over there doing that
[__] he can't be over here son [__] made
me miss paddle bro you heard those sound
oh yeah smacks oh I need that sweet spot
I it's just insane and like I don't know
assuming he sells more jackets and suits
that's a really nice Taylor shop in Hong
Kong so they've like made suits for
presidents and [__] that place yeah that
place and that guy works there and now
made it viral on Tik Tok I think it was
his dad was also doing that's what seor
sh bro we got to look into that check
his computer bro yeah the slap in the
face was crazy kind of that was a little
wild aggressive I don't want to get
suited up ever again Klein include Queen
Elizabeth Ronald rean Prince Philip King
Charles Gerald Ford hww Clinton Prince
Andrew Clinton ier Blair up that
behavior dude Michael
Jackson Richard Gear David Bowie I mean
it's
crazy yeah I mean I was weird it's weird
right you have a very strange timeline
they have a stamp a postage stamp that's
crazy yo last week I ended up being
right cuz I picked two this no no no
it's Akash is locks akos locks I got I
believe Josh Allen getting more yards
they have him at like 270 right now Josh
Allen more and then I had who did I have
getting Jordan love less I don't think
he's going to repeat the same
performance Jordan love less these are
my aash really yeah is this because the
the 49ers are just an actual good
defense got it and I do I do feel like
football is so up and down that after he
had like him and was the greatest
performance ever for a rookie
quarterback and then they brought him
back into the game and he threw one in
completion and so it became tied for the
greatest ever but it it was unbelievable
he was perfect wow and I just don't
think he can repeat that got it so so
what you're saying is sometimes in
football you're not riding the high yeah
it sound like I was setting them up
miles I wasn't but like meaning like
you're not riding the high you are
there's a come down from the high like
the high almost satisfies your
competitive instinct or whatever this is
kind of what I feel I do think momentum
is a real thing throughout the season
but sometimes you just hit such an apex
that there's really only one place to go
and in order for him to beat the 49ers
he needs to play at that level yeah and
they're just their defense is so [__]
good their pass rush is so [__] good
I just don't see it okay well that's the
prize picks prize picks.com make sure
you use the promo Cod Schultz
SZ get them picks in get that money
because you know what they're going to
do they're going to match that initial
deposit bonus uh up to $100 $100 so you
put in aund you get a free to go g you
got the AR sing locks yep okay simple as
that